hey guys it's Joanna here you have been
requesting for another kickboxing
workout video here it is this workout
will focus on your cardio stripe
endurance and core and to increase the
intensity slightly I want you to grab a
pair of really lightweight dumbbells one
kilo each or any home weighted items for
beginners you can do this workout
without any dumbbells I promise you that
it will be fun and you will be sweating
so get ready to throw me some punches
and kicks so there will be night
exercises fifty seconds of work out with
ten seconds rest interval you can't
start with five minutes warm up or treat
the first three workouts as your warmup
let's get ready and start with the first
work on squat and punches okay
squat and punch forward that's it good
so go low for your toes forward and
punch touch Ami's good and remember to
punch in line with your eyes showed us
do not punch down very nice keep going
there you go down push up with a huge
feel your butt working
punch strong punches get lunch and
remember to rotate your torso slightly
okay so slight rotation good we want to
work on our hips and our core at the
same time oh so this can be your warm-up
as well last one and rest shake it out
second workout stand in a sumo squat
position stand wide go low add
spot and week circle so just slight
rotation on your upper body and then
take your lower body good so you should
really feel your lower body pruning your
butt in your legs working and your inner
thighs and tighten your car to work on
your car with this slight rotation good
minimal movements will hurt as well keep
going slight side to side stay low do
not come up I know your legs are burning
this is only part of your warmup
stay low side to side work on your core
use your upper body to move site to site
good small movements last one more and
good shake it out next workout we are
going back to the basic left leg forward
Jack and punch okay jab punch duck and
switch punch punch
duck and switch I'm sure you know this
move good jab punch duck street job very
good job street jab punch duck speech if
you're getting tired you can either push
yourself or drop the dumbbells good be
sure to duck no switch Dhokla switch
keep going oops sorry sit jab punch die
switch get that switch stay strong
throw me though some punches get last
one duck screech and shake it out for
the excellent color get down onto the
floor and this will work in support work
on your abs I want you to curl up and
punch okay so down nice and control um
grind your abs punch forward good very
nice up punch if you find this difficult
you can bend your knees and punch
forward okay
so point your toes up punch good up
punch so really use your abs drill ABS
on the way down come up and punch nice
ah punch good keep your shoulders and
your core in tech up last few more one
more good rest get back up back to basic
of kickboxing Jack punch hooks and woo
okay let's go Jeff punch whoo-hoo left
leg forward
whoo-hoo remember it's all about
rotation in your hips at the same time
okay jet punch hook who Twitter hates
hook hook punch punch
okay okay good remember I'll animal
showed us that one do not drop low hook
hook keep going
okay hook show me those strong punches
get hook hook imagine you're punching
summer on the side forward punch sight
sight good sight sight
let's go punch punch hook hook last one
rest it out good now I want you to drop
the weight get into a plank position
stop on your right leg bring it in kick
it out and squeeze your butt good step
in a play and you should really feel
your butt and your hamstrings and a call
working just focus on one side don't
rush it nice and controlled
keep going not squeeze and get your core
and get your butt muscles if you want to
tone that but do you guys work out good
whoa-ohh
right out nice
keep going
few more seconds let's go for two more
one more and rest check it out the next
phone we want to focus on the other side
lift your way up now I want you to throw
me some front knees strike so right hand
with right knee forward okay so push
your body back slightly and throw me
those knees good I can shoot through
yoga again your hips in a co-working
throw me those knees okay so bring your
body back and throw me those knees push
your knees forward good right hand with
right knee left on this left knee good
keep going imagine you want to basically
hit someone with the knee or design
yourself with a knee good me me
go kiss going nuts forward squeeze alas
bring up one back squeeze your abs one
more breath
second last workout stand facing forward
it will be uppercut and elbows okay
let's work in your triceps up up elbows
elbows good throw all the way up to
service in palm facing out and throw me
those elbows again remember it's all in
a hip rotation up up twist please good
use a power from the hips to throw those
elbow strikes uppercut he looks rice
Epps
working good hello's twist people more
come on guys last one
and find a workout side plank so get
onto your right side okay
leave your body up and then I'm going to
reach crunch in and extend and crunch in
beginners if you find this difficult
I'll your elbow is good crunch it in
nice and controlled
extend crunch extend crunch very very
nice good stay strong keep your body up
squeeze your sides
nice this is your last workout and you
get a nice 1 minute rest after this
crunch oh nice must be more keep going
one more and just rest it out ok one
minute press and drink some water
because we want to repeat all the
workouts again ok this is your one
precious minute clip some water
you
you
you
ten more seconds get ready grab your
weights if you find that you know what
these weights are to light then by all
means you can increase your waist so
let's get ready with squad and punches
squat it down punch forward good so it's
second wrong I want you to give me your
100% energy you're going to press it up
good now that you know the moves are you
still breathing and you will help with
your workout
squat and punch good tell them punch
remember it's a bit of rotation or do
you good
squat punch next workout bob and weave
circle okay get into a sumo squat
position keep going
last one
shake it out second exercise super squad
bob and weave
circle it's going to hurt let's go dumb
slight movement keep your body upright
push your butt back tighten your core
tighten your butt do your thighs
braining your butt working and your core
with a slight rotation oh very good
okay so working on your abs it's not
always about crunches this small subtle
movements or work on your core at the
same time don't get up I do not want you
to get up not just yes I came through
the burn keep pushing do more side to
side and the romance oh my gosh check it
out next jab punch duck and switch okay
oh let's go jab punch dark switch
beginners just step over you do not have
to jump good punch pump duck speech very
nice as low as you can take your own
pace down
okay good down switch these are
lightweight but eventually it will start
to feel heavy
Jeff punch down switch good next workout
we want to work on old ass
last one down onto the foam let's roll
up and throw me a couple of punches
get ready toes pointed crunch up punch
good control down up use the ABS nice
and control punch good okay
engage that core of yours okay
nice punch you nice and control up punch
good job make sure you're plunging
straight forward and not too low punch
they'll be more last one punch and down
Oh
next we are back to left leg forward jab
punch hooks twist oh okay hip rotation
let's go jab punch okay oh good
show me your hip rotation good straight
forward good good
make sure your elbows are in line with
your arms hook hook whoever that you
want to sort of like you know you're not
too happy with imagine you are giving a
nice gentle touch to the person keep
going Oh
hook hip rotation oh oh nice hook hook
jab punch hook hook punch punch hook
hook do you more keep going do not drop
the weights last one
hook good job shake it out okay done now
we want to work on our left leg get into
a plank position crunch in extend and
squeeze good squeeze very nice
oh very good
squeeze the cheek of the bot not nice
and control good job
squeeze
whoo my hamstrings are absolutely
killing me from the squats good keep
going I am tripping and I hope you are
as well nice squeeze kick it up kick ten
more seconds okay last two more one one
more - and one more rest
oh my god I'm absolutely dripping shake
it out we don't have time
get on to the next workout okay
front knee strike left leg with left
knee okay my leg with right knee you
should feel it put as much energy as you
can as well this is not a rest go push
your knees your knees keep going I'm
dreaming and I want you to be dripping
as long Oh throw me some knees your
knees are one of the most powerful
defense go doing it miss miss Lee's neck
slightly oh use the pole from your hips
two three means good oh my god keep
going two more oh and [ __ ] out take a
last workout
stand facing forward triceps uppercut
ours let's go
okay palms facing up just to it's good
painter breathing out I can paste it out
you're almost at the end breathe deeply
and breathe out good upper cut elbow
strikes good remember with the elbows
palm facing out and twist your wrist
outwards good keep going guys I want you
to stay strong until the end over twenty
minutes
I am absolutely dripping last one come
on
and the final workout before you end
this right now it's your left side flag
okay up reach crunch it in nice and
control control your breathing and
control your body good the Chairman
hunch
very nice reach crunch good nice and
control
yes you may be shaking but they are good
shakes nice and control okay hit
straightforward is a house crunching
good crunch reach crunch must be more
plus one and just rest it hot okay just
stand up shake your legs and let's do a
quick one-minute stretch okay
just stretch your arms stretch your
elbows out slow your breathing down
okay back stretch your triceps if you
can spend more time to do those
stretches all right hold each stretch
for at least 30 seconds and repeat them
at least two times stretch it out okay
good and now I just want you to lean
forward and just stretch your hamstring
out reach up down up down
catch your breath
okay check it out - side to side and
that was it 20 minutes kickboxing
workout all time
so guys I'm sweaty I'm hot and I'm shiny
if you are sweating and dripping like me
then don't forget to like and share this
video if you really enjoy the workout
then do it again to make it a longer
cardio session you can do this three to
four times weekly to stay fit to tone up
and even to lose weight all the best for
new fitness food and motivational videos
please like share and subscribe to my
youtube channel and website do follow me
on Facebook Instagram and Twitter to
stay connected with me thanks guys
you